hello my name is reto Meier and i'm ian
ni-lewis we're kicking off 2013 by
launching our pure Android collection
here on a very special episode of the
app clinic it's been a little while
since our last app clinic but with being
hard at work during the interval testing
your apps in some pretty remote and
extreme conditions that was a tough one
for you I remember yeah I struggled but
the things I do for this team for this
job exactly i simply stayed here and
poured beer on my phone we have to do
stress testing exactly we all do what we
can well anyway we're back now and ready
to get back to work we thought the best
way to get back into the swing of things
was to remind everyone what the app
clinic is all about and what better way
to do that than by showing off some of
our graduates and officially launching
pure Android pure Android is a google
play collection that we along with roman
Nick and Adam from Android design in
action will be curating you can find it
at bit ly dart bit ly is it yeah let me
just say with Italy okay would you say
bit ly bit ly / pure Android yeah it's a
way for us to shine some light on the
Android apps that we've examined during
the app clinic often quite candidly so
you know and but they're really build
something beautiful and intuitive and
taking some of the feedback that we've
given to create something which we
really like right it's also a small way
of saying thank you to all the
developers who submit their apps to our
constructive criticism and who then turn
around and make their apps even better
and so we're going to be adding to this
list slowly so there's only a couple of
apps that will be adding today and we're
going to hope to try and find a couple
of really good examples maybe every week
maybe every other week so I've got a
little early yeah this there's lots of
great apps out there but we want to make
sure we give each app the opportunity to
really shine by itself so that's why
we're going to go slowly and every time
we do induct someone into our Hall of
Fame we're going to do it live on the
App clinic so stay tuned for the end of
the show when we're going to give you a
little more details on what it takes for
you to create an app worthy of the pure
Android title exactly so today we're in
ducting to apps into pure Android both
of which we looked at in the very early
days of Android developers live and
that's a patent by Lucas Roca and
tasks by team tasks and it's not just
because they're both using app clinic as
their color palette although that that
does tend to make me um yeah it's not
it's not going against him I'll say that
now let's tell you let's start by
looking at that I taking a look at
pattern alright so right off the bat you
can see that they've done a great job on
a Google Play feature page the branding
is really striking and it's still
entirely consistent between their logo
and their feature graphic and you can
see how this banner is really going to
stand out no matter what size it is if
it does get featured in Google Play
you're going to notice this better yeah
and you can tell them it's not just that
they've made something big and bold
they've also taken a lot of care with
the pixels themselves you know they do
have a little bit of a drop shadow but
it's not obvious just to separate
themselves the pattern from the
background and they've they've done some
design absolutely and and that's really
important for the sort of app that this
is something which is visual which
people who care about designing it to be
interested in it really pays to take
that extra step and make that extra
effort exactly it also gives you a great
idea of what the apps going to do
exactly so I throw out the app the
design language is really clean really
uncluttered it's intuitive and it's
entirely consistent with the Android
design guide you can see that as you
move through the app you never left
wondering where you are what you should
be doing the navigation is obvious the
the screen design is really clear
there's not extra stuff going on there
they've tried to keep it as visual as
possible and as non intrusive as they
can and if we look at their tablet
layouts which is sort of key as well to
being pure Android you can see that
they've implemented a fantastic
responsive design that works well both
in portrait and in landscape and us
that's really important really exciting
for me to see a great tablet experience
that works in both orientation so we
spoke to the developer of pattern Lucas
earlier and we asked him to tell us a
little bit more about his experience
building a pure Android app
hello i'm lucas Rocha i'm the creator of
pattern unique app like a wallpaper app
for android and phones and tablets
what's unique about it is that like
instead of the usual photo-based
wallpapers that you get from other apps
it offers you gives you access to more
than 200,000 patterns created by the
color levels community so and the cool
thing about working with patterns in the
context of wallpapers is that because
they are child they will always work
great on any form factor because they
don't stretch or crop or anything so it
always what works great so that's that's
the cool thing and I think that's one of
the things that is attracting a lot of
attention to the app now if i'm not
mistaken pattern was one of the first
apps to implement like proper design for
nexus 7 and i think maybe that was one
that one of the things that caught like
the attention of the google folks so so
that was an interesting thing and
actually I that I started working on the
tablet UI because of the Nexus 7 it's a
great device i love it i have one so and
as part of the process i also
implemented the 10-inch you I of course
so it just made sense so responsive
design what is like one of the like
probably one of the most challenging
things I had to do in pattern although a
pattern is a kind of in a kind of a
privileged position in terms of
scalability just because the content is
so it's so flexible in terms of like
stretching like filling areas because
we're Charlie all the time so you don't
have to worry about like you don't have
a lot of constraints in terms of the
content you are presenting so that
helped a lot so I had a lot of freedom
to like sighs things properly without
caring about like looking bad in some
form factors for example so there was
one suggestion by Roman Nurik which was
to use cred on landscape on phones and
that's something I didn't do just
because I didn't have time to but like I
definitely want to do it it's just yeah
one of those things that like details
that mattered like
make a lot of difference and I just
didn't have time to do it yet but but I
do get a lot of the inspirations from
other apps like then this is one of the
reasons i watch the show like not live
most of the time but I always try to
watch them just because especially the
designing action stuff that's especially
that series of like proposed designs
from the community that was really
inspiring and I think the the big
message from that like amount of designs
great designs that we got was that was
that like there is clearly a design
language arising in the Android platform
and that helps a lot of like especially
for like developers getting started in
the platform they they have a reference
visual design to get started if that
helps a lot especially if you're not if
you don't have a designer working with
you so that helps a lot I'm not a
designer I tend to see myself as a
developer with a with a design I two
things but so having this design
language helps a lot the thing is with
any platform like just like definitely
just going through api docs doesn't help
at all so having some discussion and
some reference designs or even reference
implementations of certain aspects of
the platform helped a lot so this is
this is where i think the design in
action shows helped a lot in terms of
like discussing one topic and maybe
talking about existing reference
implementations and like that helps a
lot implementation wise to be honest it
wasn't that challenging i think the big
thing with weather with parent was
finding the right design for for it and
i usually spend much more time thinking
about how things should look then
implementing one thing i did for pattern
that helped a lot was I did
fragment-based
implementation from the day one so i
didn't have to ring Clemente the app to
support tablets so every screen like I
started with a phone UI pretty much with
one fragment inside one activity is a
one-to-one relationship for every bit of
the UI so when I came to start working
on the tablet UI it was a natural thing
to just like put two pieces together in
a different layout so that helped a lot
I sketch a lot like he died I look at a
very thick notebook and I have like
several versions of the UI and I just
like and only start implementing when I
feel good about it it doesn't need to be
perfect but I need to be feel good about
the direction of things and that helps
in terms of like avoiding like
replanting stuff just because you change
your mind while doing something and of
course like as any like software
development you'll learn as you do like
there's nothing in software development
that is like deterministic like you know
what you're doing and you go until the
end with this same idea so as you do it
you change direction you tweak something
so I start actually like that's
something interesting about the design
of patent like I started pattern I
wanted to do something like a flick
board thing of wallpapers so it would
look like a magazine thing and in the
end I just like couldn't find a way to
make it look not right and nice so and
that was about the time I started like
the the whole hollow things started to
to to pop up so once I saw again like
once I got the design language of like
hello the ICS stuff it just felt natural
to implement something that was more in
line of androids that because Flipboard
is very early I mean it's a nice design
but it's alien it's it's not really
Android in in many ways it has some bits
of Android there but not really so right
now I'm working on two things one is
editing features so allowing to you to
change colors of exist
patterns adding brightness and
saturation this kind of thing a lot of
people ask that like they like the
pattern but didn't like the colors this
this kind of a thing and the other thing
is syncing across devices so you have
favorites your wallpaper history you
want that across all your devices and
that's something I'm working on now dr.
you today is tasks by team tasks the
tasks team have also created a strong
and consistent brand style and I'm
particularly impressed by that icon
which is both a distinctive silhouette
and also offers a really excellent
indication of what the app offers the
like pattern the learning curve to get
started with tasks is virtually
non-existent they've used a standard
action bar with icons and make it
immediately obvious how to add new items
to your list a viewpager is simple and
obvious way to switch between lists we
love it and we also love small touches
that helped make this app particularly
intuitive like the ability to drag and
drop items in the list to reorder them
they've also included some excellent
interactive widgets to use the same
design language we love us some widgets
now the tablet layout is about it
exactly what you'd expect similarly
intuitive standard multi-pane approach
with a fragment on the left and fragment
on the right which basically just
removes a level of navigation by letting
you modify your tasks while the list is
still visible notice also that on this
version they've implemented a contextual
action bar which is very tablet e so
really well done there now we also spoke
to joram from task team to find out a
little more about how he created this
pure Android experience so let's let's
listen to listen in hi my name is joram
I'm one of the developers of dead of yep
tasks from Team tasks the app is
basically designed to sync with google
tasks it's a relatively simple app where
you can like at your personal tasks and
and showering in gmail and check them
off and yeah the app is now like nine
months on Google Play was like released
in April
we had huge success with engagement and
ratings and yeah it's pretty cool app
based on the feedback of Google
developer advocates we implemented that
you can set custom reminder times for
every tasks for every task but this is
not synced with google tasks because
it's not possible and also we did like
some minor cleanup like the up button on
the home screen was pressable but they
didn't have any action so we cleaned
some stuff like that up like the change
we did for the reminder times helped
ratings and comments a lot it was like
the number one complaint about the app
that you can search custom reminder
times and I can understand why although
it's kind of hard for us because we
really designed the app to be like the
Google Tasks client you can use and as
soon as we implement functionality which
we can think we have kind of a problem
so this is kind of a trade-off between a
useful feature and not being able to
think that but it helped a lot for our
ratings and comments though the most
challenging parts relied kind of the
sink part like the whole it's it sounds
really simple like if they're to sync
all your tasks with the Google back-end
sounds really simple but it gets really
complicated because you can have nested
subtasks and then what happens if you
delete the parent what happens if the
child and all this stuff and what you
did there is kind of really tested the
whole thing so that we were sure that
the sink is working properly because the
same code is kind of the heart of the
application it's kind of the most
important stuff that the sink always
works and yeah that's that is kind of
little filly challenging but it worked
out and we had like almost no box we had
some few bugs there but we figured it
out our app adapts itself to the
different device configurations you
basically designed the app to be
compatible with like before nor three
the three main markets like the size of
the nexus for the size of a nexus 7 and
the size
nexus 10 like on a nexus 4 you just see
the task list and then if you end with
your petrol task you can edit it on a
nexus 7 it's kind of the same but if you
rotated into landscape you see your
tasks on the left and the the task
detail on the right so you can like edit
a task while viewing other tasks and on
the Nexus 10 it's still like the same
but with more spacing and bigger font
sizes and all this stuff so but we
really designed to to to work like from
the ground up you're clear like this app
has to work if all kind of devices and
Android makes it really easy i have to
say like the really powerful resource
system select the correct resources
helped to design apps with that work
with all screen sizes so our design
process likes like we do some sketches
but then like start implementing right
away because you're like more developers
and we also like it's really easy with
with the if the tool in Eclipse now to
do these mugs like writing code and
right to use it when you really want to
implement it to the whole design and we
go normally light from sketches to to
implementation right away and then
iterate of course with designers so my
very favorite part about developing on
android is that you can like this to
click you can like design one app and it
runs on like I don't know like thousand
different devices that's really great
and also Android provides a lot of
useful tools to achieve that like to
have a responsive design on area of
these devices so for example the density
independent stuff like you have it just
runs everywhere and the also down the
whole thing with fragments and and the
resource system that you can have
fragments for this device and but then
not on this screen size and that's
really that's really pleasing that you
know like now I developed
basically for testing used like these
three devices like a four-inch iphone 7
inch tablet in a 10 inch tablet and also
like a legacy device with android 2.2
for backwards compatibility but then
after that we didn't have like a single
issue that he didn't run a device that
was really great that you have like four
devices to test and it runs everywhere
so our next steps for for the app is
kind of to integrate the emails into the
test you know there there is a featuring
team every can like add an email to your
task list and we just don't show it on
the device so we really would like to
sync all these emails down for the
device and as soon as you click on the
link that you can see the email in the
mobile web browser or stuff besides that
we are also looking with integrating our
data with the third party widgets like I
don't know like like simple simple which
it's whatever they're like a lot of lots
of them and they are all asking for for
a content provider that we provide so
they can the users can like show their
tasks on the customer to really
customized widgets yeah that's kind of
what you're looking what you're looking
for a to build so congratulations to
pattern and tasks for making it into
pure Android for the rest of you here's
your opportunity to find out how you too
can join these illustrious ranks let's
start with the basics so yes it is sort
of four key things that you need to
consider to even be in the running for
us to consider you and those are great
assets having a great quality app having
a great quality tablet app and following
the Android design guidelines so let's
look at a little each of these in a
little bit more detail this is really
are pretty basic I mean for the assets
we're looking for something that's going
to help us help you sell your
application absolutely the people that
work for Google Play
really want to help you sell your app
but they can't do that if your assets
look like garbage or if they're not even
there all right so we can't we will
probably not even look at your app on
the App clinic if you don't at least
have your feature graphic you're you
know basically all of the assets which
you need to specify in Google Play done
so i think back here we've actually got
your app right right so we do this
you're a luxury is that i would like to
take some credit for the for the assets
here i can't take any i actually your
doctor friend it it was actually not my
doctor friend in this instance it was
Roman who actually put together these
quite impressive looking very nice
although so what's the one in the middle
on the on the bottom right right here
that that is that's enough quick but but
that's a is that the feature graphic is
the feature graphic you okay cuz the
contrast a little weird they've contrast
is a little off yeah so which probably
fixed that come on these are you yeah
exactly it's a really good point though
you need to have a feature graphic in
order for us to feature you yeah because
that's the graphic that actually gets
put on the market or on the on the
google play store or in the collection
and we can't you know automatically use
any of these other graphics that graphic
has to be there yeah and also take note
of things like you'll note that all of
the apps that we feature today all had
both phone screen shots and tablet
screen shots and another thing that you
should also consider is including a
promotional video and you can see there
is a link for one here online basically
want to do everything you can to help
the Google Play team merchandise your
app absolutely the promo video a lot of
people forget but it's an absolute
no-brainer it's absolutely the the most
effective way that we've found to sell
people on your app once you've moved
beyond that what we really want you to
look at is the app quality guidelines
now this is something that you can find
on developer.android.com on the
distribute tab under Google Play quality
core and this these are really sort of
the fundamental thing so again when we
have people internally looking at what
apps can we feature what things can we
put into pure Android this is basically
a checklist of things which we're going
to look at as sort of your bare minimum
entry requirements for what we consider
that to be a quality app now a lot of
people don't know the story behind these
burrito and I actually spent months work
on these pages on convincing the team to
post those guidelines because originally
we just had a set of internal QA
guidelines that we would run any
candidate for featuring past and if they
failed those guidelines they'd have to
either fix it or not get featured and it
took a long time to get everyone
involved to agree to post these
guidelines online but they finally are
there for you they really are the
guidelines that our QA team uses to
figure out whether an app is feature
bowl or not so if you're not meeting
these guidelines you are not meeting the
lowest bar exactly so this is something
you should spend a lot of time looking
over and basically as part of your own
release QA checklist this is what we
recommend you do is go through this make
sure that your meeting all of these
requirements and then you'll know that
you have an app that is you know quality
it meets those those quality guidelines
of course just having an app isn't good
enough we also want that apt to look
great on different devices and this year
we are all about tablets so it's got to
look great on tablets exactly you can
find the tablet app quality checklist
also on on Google Play its quality /
tablet and so you'll find here a bunch
of best practices which we look at to
say well is this a tablet office it's
not a table that this is basically what
we're going to look at and what we
recommend you look out to say well this
meets that bar this is something which
we think tablet users are going to be
able to use and enjoy on their devices
and finally we've got the Android design
guideline an oldie but a goodie so this
is something which we also launched last
year really exciting a developer android
com / design this tells you how to make
an app which looks like an Android app
now there is a huge amount of variation
we don't want every app to look the same
sort of some sort of cookie cutter mold
that's kind of boring but there are
certain principles which you can conform
to which are going to make sure that
every Android user feels comfortable
once they get into the app and this is
something which the Android design in
action guys spend a lot of time talking
about on that Tuesday show yeah this is
when the way we got these is by hiring
an excellent design team and letting
them run loose for a while until they
figured out exactly what the design
language of ice cream
sandwich was going to be and even though
we expect that to evolve we don't expect
that to ever completely change the way
it did an ice cream sandwich again this
is for the foreseeable future what
android apps should look like unless you
have a really good to not make them look
that way so once you've sort of gone
through and created all of these you
know these sort of basic requirements
for building an app which we're going to
be really excited about are going to be
willing to feature on our own collection
and I'm a collector we're going to put
our names against there's a few I think
just your names on it right now it's
just my name I don't think you're quite
they're comfortable yet but nonetheless
um the next thing we're looking for is
something which makes it even purer over
android than just those basic criteria
and these are things which are kind of
ephemeral this isn't stuff that you can
easily define in a checklist you know we
want something that's really efficient
that's buttery smooth that gives you
this sort of magical experience when
you're using the app and you know launch
and you're like oh this is this is kind
of just totally works yeah it feels
right exactly and inefficient I think
we're talking about you know how easy is
it to get tasks done in the app buttery
on the other hand I think we're really
referring to the efficiency of your code
absolutely and that one actually
personally I can measure if your if your
code isn't running consistently at 30 to
60 FPS on a newer device then it's not
buttery exactly we're also looking at
efficiency and butteriness in terms of
things like your battery life you know
you don't want to have the use of being
conscious of the fact that your app is
doing anything other than running
without draining your battery at all I
think a good example of you know sort of
that delightful aspect is something like
pattern which is it creates attractive
wallpapers or allows you to browse
attractive wallpapers now I don't really
change the wallpapers on my app but I
found myself when looking at this app
just sort of flicking through and just
having fun with something which isn't
necessarily you know something I
normally would whereas tasks delighted
me even though it is the simplest at
possible they just didn't get anything
wrong yeah all I wanted was a task list
I didn't need a skeuomorphic design I
didn't need bells and whistles I just
need to task
this that worked exactly the way I
expected it to work and everything that
they added whether it's a list drag and
drop or whatever was something that
added to my sense of the app responding
the way I expected it to absolutely so I
think that they're pretty much wraps up
first today so tune into a room and Nick
and Adam for Android design in action on
Tuesday they're going to be doing a
design exploration on a soccer or
football depending on what country
you're in app and they're gonna be doing
a deep dive on Launcher icons as well
and we're going to follow their lead so
next Friday we'll be looking at sports
train tracking and if you've got a
device profile after you liked it it
goes take a look at be sure to let us
know to put acesso put everything you
want into the Trello page this is where
we're going to be collecting nominations
for the apps that we're going to look at
and sort of listing the categories which
are under consideration so this is where
you self nominate to possibly be part of
the pure Android collection so we're
going to start digging through the
archives of the app clinic app reviews
over the last year or so to try and find
more pure Android candidates we already
have a short list of apps which we're
pretty excited about which we're going
to start rolling out but if you've made
some changes to your app recently or
since we reviewed it and you'd like us
to take another look and put it into
consideration do let us know on google+
and and we will add it to our queue and
hopefully it'll make the cut so until
then I'm rademeyer and i'm ian ni-lewis
and this is being the app clinic